oh i was right i was right
i was right i'm not right all the time
but it is awesome when i
am unless i happen to be wrong right i
mean we're kind of going off what we saw
it could be that like in episode number
eight agatha's like this is not the dark
hold it's the light hold
it's like the dark hole but less evil i
don't know that's really what she's
gonna do
but i have a very very very strong
feeling that it is but the question is
what does it mean
right it's one thing to see it it's
another to see the revelation from
episode number seven that agatha
harkness
is basically the one behind everything
but what does it mean right because the
big question to kind of ask here is like
what does agatha harkness gain from this
right now in reality
i think episode number seven just gave
us the plot to doctor strange too i
think it just basically told us
everything that's going to happen so one
of the big things to kind of go on here
let's let's let's sort of let's let's
talk about the doctor strange two
portion
let's talk about doc strange two portion
for a second so the big thing that
people are taking away from this or
looking at doctor strange two on is
they're saying like nightmare mephisto
is gonna be the main villain stuff like
that i've
combed through like all the confirmed
castings i've combed through
probably two or three dozen news
articles and i have not seen
anything that's confirmed mephisto or
nightmare for doctor strange too and so
because of that i kind of look at this
and i'm like all right so
what if the main villain really is wanda
like what if she really is the bad guy
here one division ends and she goes on
to be the main villain in doctor strange
too now what does that mean why does
this have anything to do with anything
okay cool so here's what i think is
going on right let's start with agatha
let's start with agatha hartness the big
revelation the fact that she's the bad
guy here
why is she the bad guy well there's a
couple different ways we can go with
this we can say that she really is just
a dick right she's just she's just a
terrible person and that's really all it
is like she's always been bad right she
was alive during the salem witch trials
and she was actually a witch
and they were gonna burn her at the
stake and maybe she used her magic to
escape or something like that or we
could say that she was just a person who
was in the wrong place at the wrong time
that when she was talking to vision for
example that she wandered down the wrong
street
now that kind of doesn't really seem to
hold up because we saw in like her own
little intro which was awesome by the
way she got her own theme music when it
was revealed that she was a bad guy that
she was basically playing vision right
she wasn't actually under wanda's spell
and i think it's safe to believe she's
never been under one dispel she's never
been controlled by wanda she's just been
playing the part so that wanda
and us don't really know what's going on
but we could say that like she's a
person who's a bad guy
and she made a bargain with like cathone
or somebody like that now we may never
see them or it could just be she fell
under the influence of the dark hole but
by whatever manner and whatever means
agatha became a bad guy and she's
basically just been a bad guy ever since
manipulating events doing all kinds of
really crappy and crazy things but how
does this tie into wanda
why would wanda be somebody sought after
by agatha what could her grand plan be
you kind of have to expect there to be
one you have to expect it to be some
kind of a plan
in a situation like this when you have
somebody like wanda who has all these
kind of crazy and wonky powers and when
you look at the show in its entirety and
you look at all the things that agatha
said there's stuff that wanda can do
that agatha didn't even know she could
do right like for example when the kids
were asking her to like bring the dog
back and juan is like i can't resurrect
the dead i think it was legitimate when
agatha was like you can do that like you
can resurrect the dead and juana was
like no i can't do that i think that was
a legitimate reaction like damn i knew
you were powerful i didn't know you were
that powerful like i think it was like
that but i think it was an
actual true statement on behalf of
agatha really genuinely
totally oblivious to the fact that wanda
could potentially resurrect the dead
when you look at like pietro being there
right i don't think agatha brought
pietro back and i don't think he's an
illusion she created i think wanda did
it i think wanda brought back pietro i
think agnes
guided pietro to wanda's house but i
think wanda actually resurrected him
from the dead
wanda i think is just absurdly powerful
now here's the thing that i i think is
kind of going on here
i think agatha is legitimately a bad guy
agatha's just been doing bad things
and in the aftermath of age of ultron or
the aftermath of infinity war or
avengers in-game or whatever agatha
became aware of wandan maybe she wanted
to turn her into like her prized people
that could help her do evil things or
something like that doesn't really
matter what it is
the result of this is that agatha
brought wanda under her spell
and that's what led to wanda stealing
the body of vision and that's what led
to wanda creating this little reality or
something like that maybe it's agatha
testing her to see how powerful she is
but i think what's gonna happen is
agatha's gonna realize she bit off more
than she can chew
because i think one of the big
revelations that's gonna come out of
this is that wanda's kids were never
real that agatha created them right
agatha created them as an illusion for
wanda or
prodded wanda into doing it now i know a
lot of people will point to the idea of
no no
it's gotta be the events of the comics
where they're pieces of mephisto soul
but it's like i was talking about in a
previous video
even for a comic book film that kind of
stretches the limits of credulity even
for a comic book
concept it's a little far-fetched to put
into a movie and so if we bring it back
to reality make it a little more
tangible and we say okay like agatha
created wanda's kids then the revelation
that's gonna come out of this is one is
gonna find out they're not real and
she's gonna find out that agatha's the
one that's been controlling all this
that this whole world that wanda lives
in
is all just done at the manipulations of
agnes and wanda's gonna lose it she's
gonna
absolutely freak out and when she does
she's gonna go dark phoenix right that's
basically what's gonna happen i thought
you guys don't know what that means dark
phoenix saga marvel comics right this is
why i say
wanda in the marvel cinematic universe
is basically jean grey from the comics
and she has been
for a long long time okay so the phoenix
force in the comics represents the sum
total of all life that has ever
currently does and will ever exist
at some point on the line it became
aware of jean grey's existence and said
hey she's a perfect host for me i'm
gonna bond to her when she gets older
and it did that was the phoenix saga now
what ended up happening
is jean grey was ultimately manipulated
by a guy named
jason wingard who had the ability to
manipulate the five senses but when you
got to the end
of what was essentially the phoenix saga
and it was believed by jean grey that
cyclops had died she had a psychotic
break and the phoenix force totally took
over and just experiencing all these
crazy emotions vengeance rage different
things like that and just went
absolutely nuts and just became an evil
phoenix and i feel i feel like that's
basically what's gonna happen with wanda
right that wanda
really does have a ton of power right
when her her abilities were activated
quote unquote by the
mind stone of the space stone or
whatever it was the tesseract during age
of ultron by baron von strucker when we
were first introduced to her in
quicksilver
that on the surface it looked like all
it activated was her telepathy and
telekinesis what it did activate was so
much more because you're talking about
matter manipulation so you guys you
don't know in marvel comics the ability
to manipulate matter on a universal
level which is to say
creating planets or moving them around
and things like that it's like five
steps away from telekinesis
right at the end of the day telekinesis
is just moving objects with your mind
with enough training and assuming that
the story needs to be told and marvel
wants to have it that way they can take
a character that can move trains with
their mind
and then like expand their abilities to
the point where they're so fine-tuned
they can move like atoms and molecules
with their mind and so that's what
you're talking about with wanda right if
wanda's actual power is the ability to
manipulate reality but up to this point
it's only really surfaced as like
telepathy and telekinesis and this
psychotic break she experiences at the
hands of this revelation that agatha's
behind everything
basically unlocks all of her abilities
she just loses her mind and taps into
her full potential then you're gonna see
something that basically goes into the
dark phoenix saga territory where she
basically becomes insane
she loses her mind she goes nuts and
becomes the villain that leads into
doctor strange too and you've got
stephen strange and baron mordo teaming
up to try to take down wanda maximoff
and basically just chasing her around
the multiverse right so that's why you
end up seeing
sam raimi's spider-man andrew garfield
spider-man like all these different
characters from across the various kind
of book movies that have existed out
there i wouldn't be surprised if at the
end of doctor strange too
wanda's defeated but the price for her
defeat comes in the form of like quote
unquote the multi-versus destruction and
the only way to fix it is to condense it
all down and so like the marvel
cinematic universe the fox universe the
sam remy spider-man universe they all
just get condensed down into one
singular universe and then what do you
know you got x-men in the marvel
cinematic universe done just like that
so i feel like that's
basically what's gonna happen going into
like doctor strange two and all that
kind of stuff
i feel like this this this gave us huge
answers just
enormous answers with everything that
was going on in one division but again
at the end of the day this is just a
theory but if you guys want to learn
more about the dark hole i'm gonna have
a video coming up on comments explained
that will properly explain the darkhold
i'll have that later on today it'll just
be marvel comics the darkfold explained
so it's not up yet at the time this
video is being released on youtube but
it will be within a few hours those of
you guys who are kind of coming over
here from comics explained yes we are
doing wanda vision yes
it is something similar to comics
explain but i'm trying to create a clear
line here where comics explained
only focuses on comics and nothing else
pop culture explained focuses on
everything else that's not necessarily
related to comic books but it's not
comic books per se right so like
the one division tv show or maybe falcon
in the winter soldier if the first
episode's good i have no idea but
nonetheless thank you for watching guys
if you want to see more about my easter
eggs and theories and all that kind of
stuff on one division make sure you guys
click this end screen which will take
you there and make sure you guys also
check out our videos on like celebrities
explained and stuff like that we don't
want to just be one division right we
don't want to kill our channel when one
division ends we want to have
other stuff for you guys to see so make
sure you guys go check those things out
and i will catch you all later
peace